I'm assuming by now that most of you
have seen Jurassic world it came out on
Friday a lot of people are seeing this
movie it's making a ton of money I've
already done my spoiler free review so
if you want a spoiler free review that
is on my channel right now it's the last
video I did but this video is going to
be entirely about spoilers I'm going to
talk in detail about some of the things
I loved about the movie as well as some
of the things I didn't like about the
movie because in my review I was sort of
general about things by saying I didn't
like certain subplots and that's because
I like to walk into a movie knowing as
little as possible and I try to preserve
that experience for you guys because a
lot of people just view a spoiler as he
or she dies but now I can finally just
breathe and talk about these things in
detail so let's talk about the things
first that I really loved about Jurassic
world for one as I mentioned Chris Pratt
was awesome in this movie and for some
reason the line of his that I laughed
the most at was hey hey don't give me
that shit I don't know why I just was
Alerus I was great line his line
delivery was perfect in the movie he was
a badass him shooting down the
dimorphodon and everything one of my
favorite shots in the entire movie is
when he's on his motorcycle the Raptors
are next to him and he sort of looks
left and right for a second and smiles
for a second like holy shit this is
actually happening this is awesome and
although I thought there was over
reliance on CGI I did really like the
indominus rex I thought she was crazy
she was frightening the stuff she was
able to pull off the smart thing she did
and of course the camouflage my mouth
dropped in that moment what disappointed
me though was that they never really
went on with that in the movie ever
again it was just that one really cool
predator moment where it was like oh
shit that thing in camouflage and then
it just never really happened again and
of course the bit where you realized
that she's part Raptor and the Raptors
now turn on the humans all that stuff
was great because you go into this movie
people who are worried about the Raptors
being little baby toy things that hunt
for humans and they had some pretty
badass moments themselves and I was very
satisfied with that and as I said in my
review one of the most emotionally
resonant connections I felt in the movie
was actually between Chris Pratt and the
Raptors and that was handled really well
especially towards the end when he has
to focus and sort of body language
communicate to tell blue to go after the
IREX it was great stuff I loved it and
the inclusion of the
a source Rex at the end was beautiful I
adored it it was one of my favorite
parts of the entire movie although the
CGI wasn't quite perfect in my opinion
it didn't really look as good and
actually as Jurassic Park or lost world
I felt the CGI wasn't as good as I
wanted it to be for the t-rex but I
loved how she was old and beaten and
just ripped up because it actually is
the t-rex from the original Jurassic
Park although you wouldn't really know
they never say in the movie which is
kind of stupid but the director has come
out and said that so that's cool all in
all as you guys know I had a lot of fun
with this movie I had a good time
watching it I was disappointed though
that it wasn't really as deep as some of
the other Jurassic Park films
particularly the first one it wasn't
much of a theme here it was really just
dinosaurs run from them
similar to Jurassic Park 3 it's just
that this movie does it a whole lot
better so let's get into some of the
things I didn't like about this movie in
spoiler rific detail in my original
review I mentioned there were too many
subplots and I left it at that because I
didn't wanna let you guys know too many
things I mentioned that the kids sort of
derailed the film a little bit I liked
their performances I thought they worked
really well in the movie I liked ty
Simpkins a lot I actually thought he was
really good in this movie and his older
brother but what was so unnecessary to
me was the whole divorce subplot with
his parents it's mentioned in really one
scene whether on the monorail he starts
crying about the mail from different
lawyers and they discover their parents
are probably going to get a divorce now
the reason I'm saying this doesn't
really work for me is because it's never
mentioned again it's never really used
as a way to flesh out these characters
except for that one scene which tells me
that someone said hey we should probably
flesh out the kids a little more okay
we'll do the one conversation on the
monorail about them getting a divorce
and then we'll never talk about it again
because it doesn't matter right so they
tried to flesh out the kids by giving
them a backstory but they never again in
the film allowed that to affect them it
was just one scene that felt almost like
it was a reshoot just to give the kids a
little more something to be thinking
about but by far the biggest subplot
that I thought was just really stupid in
this movie that I didn't want to mention
in my original review because I didn't
know about it going in so I wanted you
guys to have that experience to the
military subplot I loved Vincent
D'Onofrio he is one of my favorite
actors he is so underrated men in black
full-metal-jacket dare
well the guy is great and he's good in
this movie but the fact that his
character wants to weaponize Raptors is
so stupid it's stupid for two reasons
for one in a real world application
that's one of the worst ideas I've ever
heard of my life can you imagine that
the good guys and the bad guys the good
guys have the Raptors the Raptors go out
they attack the enemy the good guys are
getting wounded in the process by enemy
gunfire the Raptors kill all the enemy
they turn around they see the good guys
some of them are bloodied some of them
smell like meat and the Raptors just
ignore that apparently and just go to
the barracks and sleep with a good guy
like what does that even mean of course
the Raptors are going to turn on the
good guys and eat them it's such a
stupid idea
that's dumb reason number one dumb
reason number two is because it honestly
is a gigantic cliche how many movies
have we seen where someone invents
something or has some form of scientific
technology that's impressive or somebody
from the military doesn't come in and
wants to turn it into a weapon for uses
of war it's in like so many movies it's
such a gigantic cliche movie should have
really focused down more just on our
main characters Bryce Dallas Howard and
Chris Pratt and allowed the movie to
flow through them because one of my
biggest issues with the film was that it
wasn't really as intense or as
suspenseful or frightening as it could
have been because when characters are
doing some of these things that are
scary like Chris Pratt and the Raptors
and the soldiers in the woods and the
camouflage IREX and all that stuff is so
good it then cuts back to Vincent
D'Onofrio kind of wandering around and
talking to people about engine cuts back
to the kids watching Jimmy Fallon making
jokes and these shifting tones don't
allow the entire film to feel as scary
as it could be because just think about
Jurassic Park when the power goes out in
Jurassic Park every single character in
the film is dealing with that problem
and it feels so intense because of that
and the control-room sequences in
Jurassic Park were so suspenseful and
featured really innovative camerawork
that just really made the scenes as good
as they can be the direction for the
control-room sequences in this film
Jurassic world I felt were very flat
that's what I mentioned in my review I
said some of the directions a little
flat I was referring to the control-room
sequences because a lot of those
sequences and I watched the film twice
now I took my mom the other day a lot of
those sequences are just
cut to a close-up cut to a close-up cut
to a close-up cut to a close-up over and
over again and there isn't really that
much interesting stuff going on there
with the camera and there's one attempt
in this movie to really get a lot of
comedy out of taking Efron Khan's
character I may have said his name
incorrect I'm sorry sir he plays
essentially Hammond in this movie except
he's not emotionally invested in the
dinosaurs he's just financially invested
in them they keep going for this joke
that he's learning how to fly and
getting his helicopters license and it
just does not work at one point he turns
around the camera pans in on him and
he's like we don't get anyone else and
he gets inside the helicopter I was like
whoa that wasn't funny at all I was
really cheesy I don't know if it was the
direction or his acting but when the
helicopter crashes it was like the worst
acting I've seen in this entire film
this guy is dying the helicopter is
crashing and this is what the shot looks
like that part was awful also the fact
that the kids were able to start that
Jeep with 22 year old fuel I don't know
about that one I'm not a car expert but
that seems a little far-fetched to me
and it's kind of funny because I
realized the ending of this film has
extreme similarities to the ending of
the first Jurassic Park our heroes are
cornered by Raptors in the first Jaypee
film and are then saved by a t-rex at
the end of Jurassic world our heroes are
cornered by raptors and indominus rex
and then saved by a t-rex it's kind of
interesting and then the Raptors save
them too so it was sort of like a twist
on the first film which I didn't really
need I wanted something a little more
original unless like hey remember
Jurassic Park was really good yeah we
think it's good too here's the part
that's sort of liked it and you guys may
think I'm complaining a lot but I'm
really not I like the movie I'm just
talking completely in depth about why I
didn't give the film an A+ and why it
went down to a B for me these are all
the reasons some people complain that
the girl dying was way way way too
drawn-out
I can understand why you'd say that but
a lot of people are like well you know
she didn't do anything if this happened
in real life you really think the
dinosaurs are just going to eat the
really bad people to them it's just meat
and I understand what most people are
saying that the scene was too drawn-out
but whatever look what I just I just
loved in this movie was the fight with
the t-rex and the IRA
the Raptors all of that was just so much
fun because when the irx was about to
kill the Tyrannosaurus I was like you're
kidding me you're gonna pull a jp3
you're gonna make this thing kill the
t-rex that quick and you're gonna piss
me off and then the Raptor saved him it
was awesome t-rex came in there and then
the Mosasaurus just came out and it was
great I loved it I was just like yes
that's what I need that's awesome and
last but not least one thing I really
did love by the movie and by far one of
the scenes that got me the most was when
Chris Pratt held the one dinosaur head
as it died and he just kind of pet the
head and everything in brightest Isles
Howard was crying because that was an
animatronic and it worked so well we
needed more animatronics in this movie
all in all though guys I had a good time
with Jurassic world I'm gonna buy the
blu-ray I've already seen it twice I'm
looking forward to seeing it again it is
not as good as the first two in my
opinion but it is way better than three
so guys let me know what you thought of
Jurassic world below those are all my
spoiler if ik details about the film and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes